des transat rose ont pris place devant
la médiathèque du canal et le musée de
la ville de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
les terrasses de l'été sont de retour
jusqu'au 26 août c'est l'occasion de
faire une petite pause pour les passants
ouais c'est très bien même moi très bien
pourquoi une demi-heure trois quart
d'heure là puis après son calme ouais
parce qu'en plus ça permet de sortir et
tout ça force un peu aussi à sortir donc
c'est bien et puis dès que j'aurai fini
le tome 1 j'ai le tome de tout juste à
côté alors que chez moi une heure de
trajet une heure de aller-retour c'est
un peu trop j'ai j'habite juste à côté
et puis j'ai vu qu'il y a des chaises
des trucs comme ça et puis comme ça ils
vont pas s'ennuyer à la maison qui vont
faire des activités des il y a plein de
choses au programme des Jeux de société
pour petits et grands des coloriages et
des livres à disposition l'objectif
c'est d'offrir un espace libre d'accès
simple convivial où les gens peuvent se
rencontrer se détendre discuter et puis
ça permet aussi de faire découvrir le
musée et médiathèque sous un autre
regard un petit peu plus simple c'est
nous qui sortons et qu'à l'envers les
gens et pas l'inverse les mercredis et
samedi différentes activités sont
proposées mercredi dernier le musée de
la ville animé un atelier sur
l'urbanisme cet atelier de là il est
autour en fait des espaces verts et déjà
d'un nom chaque enfant est invité à
créer sa maquette qui peut ressembler à
ceci par exemple avec un petit cours
d'eau des espaces évidemment qui sont
plus verdoyants des petits chemins et
des choses qu'on peut mettre dans les
jardins pour que les enfants s'y
retrouvent et aiment y aller aussi
évidemment c'est qu'il soit un peu
eux-mêmes des paysagistes des urbanistes
en fait qui touchent un peu ces métiers
là c'est quoi le métier d'anarchitecte
c'est quoi le métier de ce en fait qui
font la ville d'autres ateliers sont
programmés ou encore des spectacles avec
notamment le passage de la compagnie Les
Tréteaux de France le 5 août